you're watching the season finale I'm
going underground with me action return
see just hours after European
parliamentarians awarded Julian Assange
its most prestigious prize for
journalists whistleblowers and defenders
of the right to information we will ask
the UN Special Rapporteur on torture by
the British capture and imprisonment of
the WikiLeaks founder but first straight
to New York to speak to legendary Pink
Floyd frontman Roger Waters about
whether the actions of Teresa May Donald
Trump and then in Marino against Assange
a symptomatic of rogue States
Roger thanks for coming on the show
let's just start with what went through
your mind when you saw the pictures of
Assange being dragged out of the
Ecuadorian Embassy in London by British
police we'd been warned for several days
because WikiLeaks had got wind of the
fact that they were going to actually do
this but to see them physically carrying
him out special I don't know Special
Branch I suppose and putting him in that
van and driving him away was absolutely
chilling to think that the UK has become
such a willing accomplice and satellite
of the American Empire that it would do
such a thing in contravention of all
laws moral ethical and actual legal
restrictions is absolutely stunningly
appalling and makes me ashamed to be an
Englishman I know you have campaigned
against environmental destruction in
Ecuador under the Lenin Moreno
administration what do you think is
behind the decision to let UK police in
to the embassy to capture him John
Pilger said on this show that it would
be a warning from history they bribed
him with a promise of a 4.7 billion IMF
loan I may say that their Khamenei does
not end with that getting Moreno to give
up Julian Assange also they have plans
to let Chevron start drilling for oil in
Ecuador's most important national park
which is a travesty beyond all
imagination but let's stick to Julian
the law in the United States after the
Patriot
and 102 - 102 1 the amendments to it
citizens barely have rights anymore
everything is at the whim of the
commander-in-chief and the
commander-in-chief is anything is
allowed now there is no law there is no
recourse to the law something I've
written about in lots of my songs over
the years because it's when the law goes
that we find ourselves pitched in two
world wars and at this team at the
moment Bolton and Abrams and Trump
himself and pence and all the rest of
them are desperately trying to pitch the
world the planet that we live on into
the third world war sorry I'm drifting
off Julian who we should all be focusing
on because he is who the whole world
should be focusing on him now because if
we let the UK get away with allowing him
to be extradited to the United States
and we allow the United States
government at their whim to torture him
and to detain him possibly for the rest
of his life we will have allowed them
several steps further down the road to
absolute tyranny and probably the
destruction of the planet that's my view
it's hugely important the British people
need to stop their government from
allowing this to happen Lenin Moreno
would say that there is nothing bribe
about bribery here he would say it's not
the CIA base at Manta Bay the IMF in
fact he had an exclusive in The Guardian
once WikiLeaks media partner which
claimed that actually Julian Assange was
some kind of spy against Moreno in the
embassy Moreno the president of Ecuador
now would say anything to make 10
shillings he this is a man of absolutely
no substance and no moral Center and no
compass he is only interested in that
and
really lies constantly and consistently
Teresa May told Parliament here to
welcome massages capture and apparently
70 MPs in Parliament have signed a
letter saying this is about sex
allegations in Sweden not war crimes
that's why he's in Belmarsh prison in
southeast London he saved yourself
Donald Trump once sing well well that's
absolute nonsense as we know those
charges have all been dropped long ago
there are no charges standing against
him except some spurious and very minor
bond or bail charge under UK law which
is completely prepared to face under
normal circumstances of jurisprudence in
the UK the only reason he didn't earlier
was because he was frightened that as
lackeys of the American Empire the UK
establishment would have him extradited
to the USA which is what it looks as if
they're trying to do to resume comes
from a long line of lackeys a long long
line Cameron before her and Blair before
him we we've all seen what's happened
since the Second World War with the
moving away from the welfare state that
the ATLA government put in place after
the Second World War
towards more and more and more
dependence upon the United States with
the nuclear submarine bases and in
Scotland and so on and so on and so
forth so we know that we are under the
thumb well we the British people need to
get out from under the thumb and say no
this is wrong this is illegal this is a
journalist and anybody who says no is
not a journalist yes he is all you need
to be to be a journalist is somebody who
has access to a press they used to be
printing presses back in the day when
the laws were written now
it's access to the internet or anything
where you give information to your
fellow citizens of the world any
information doesn't matter what it is
but the most important information that
we julian assange his fellow citizens of
the globe need is information about the
secret Malfi ants and wrongdoing of our
governments which are legend and Julian
Assange along with Chelsea Manning and
Edward Snowden and the other
whistleblowers down the years are the
heroes who help us to gain some of the
knowledge that the powers that be would
keep secret if they could this is in
countries that call themselves
democracies where the government is
supposed to be for the people not for
the corporations not for Donald Trump
not for Elliott Abrams not for Mike
Pence not for Pompeo not for the rest of
those rabid animals who are in charge of
everything but for We the People just to
be clear obviously so WikiLeaks doesn't
sue us obviously there were never any
charges in Sweden just allegations but
you call him a journalist why do you
think so many journalists are attacking
Julian Assange and is it a coincidence
that those journalists often like the
European Union and the Trump
administration also say support the
overthrow of the Venezuelan government
there's a intersection there why are
journalists attacking Julian and saying
he's not a journalist why do so many
journalists buy the narrative that in
Venezuela which you just mentioned for
instance that Maduro is a vicious
dictator and the people are being AB and
bla and buy the story to keep their jobs
that's why because if they express
opinions that go against the narrative
of the powers-that-be
mmm word filters down in one way or
another they suddenly find that they're
not getting the plum job they're not
getting the
motion they're not getting that your job
is on the line if you stand up to them
I'm guessing obviously I don't know some
of them may just be so dumb that they
can't figure out the truth
he collects information from sources
which he protects he sometimes helps
those sources to collect the information
or not and then he publishes the
information that he gets if he believes
it to be real and true and in the public
interest for him to publish it and he's
not a journalist what is he then
what is Julian Assange if he's not I'm a
you're a journalist all of us this is
journalism we are trying to find out the
truth about things and not explain it to
the public but to make it available to
the public it's called freedom of
information and it is absolutely central
to the working of any healthy form of
government including democracies and
that is what they're trying to prevent
because they don't want their secrets to
come out they want to keep everything
secret they don't want us to know about
their methods of torture or their
incarceration of innocent people or all
that's why they're going after Julian
Assange because he is of thorn in their
side also what they're trying to do
Trump and the rest of them and to resume
is they're trying to frighten would-be
Julian Assange's who may provide this
incredibly important service for the
rest of us in society in the future
they're trying to scare them off so they
won't do it they're trying to make an
example of Julian Assange rather than
doing what the EU has just done untold
yesterday and give him awards for
telling the truth for blowing the
whistle Julie Julian Assange also
released unconventional regime change
policy documents from the United States
obviously secret plans to destroy Syria
let alone the more famous US war crimes
in Iraq a connection between all of
these documents that WikiLeaks
distributed and how come you realize all
of this when say as regards Venezuela
policy Richard Branson held a Live Aid
concert to support US and EU policy why
do you know and people like Branson
don't Branson's not in transom is not
interested in the reality Branson is
interested in candy floss and Branson he
doesn't care about politics in my view
he couldn't care less he's interested in
making a splash for Branson anybody who
knows him will tell you that well II D
actually he broadcasts it to be fair to
him he doesn't hide the fact that he's a
fluffy opportunist who really has no
interest in anything real except his own
eco but you you all you I was in touch
with people in Venezuela all the way
through February who were there
reporting out of Venezuela friends of
mine and and I was asking pertinent
questions about what was actually going
on and so if anybody did any research
and didn't just listen to the narrative
that was being repeated over and over
again Maduro is a dictator the people
are starving the u.s. is trying to help
them with humanitarian aid we have to
black and then suddenly out of the
woodwork after a phone call from who who
had pence from pence guido pops out of
the woodwork and says hello I'm the new
president Mike Pence says so oh hold on
a minute
wouldn't the people of Venezuela say so
shouldn't they have some part in this
and by the way Maduro has not ridden
roughshod over the constitution of the
of venezuela the constitution of venice
Baelor is extremely important to Maduro
and to most of the people in Venezuela
it's not important to Guido because he
plays fast and loose with it he lies
about it he changes he takes it out of
context Roger Waters I'll stop you there
more from Roger Waters as well as the UN
Special Rapporteur on torture professor
niels Meltzer after the break
[Music]
welcome back I'm still here with actress
of Pink Floyd frontman Roger Waters
Bernie Sanders the front-runner arguably
of the DNC to challenge Trump in 2020 he
complained about Maduro and has said
nothing about Julian Assange at all as
far as I can tell our politicians
fearful of taking the kind of political
positions you have of course they're
fearful I actually I used Twitter very
little but after the Venezuelan comments
from Bernie Sanders where he made
sweeping statements about Maduro and ie
he was repeating the narrative it
doesn't matter what I tweeted he kind of
discredit us himself and I'm really
sorry to see it because in terms of
domestic policy and Bernie Sanders has
done a great deal of good in the United
States to push the argument to a more
progressive position so I kind of feel
for Bernie Sanders who I admire in some
ways but of course he's scared that he's
gonna make a mistake and that'll be the
end of his tilt at the 2020 election you
know you only have to see the way some
of the new progressives in Congress or
even people who've been there for a few
years get attacked for making any kind
of an anti-war statement well actually
can only tell sick about something new
women you know poverty OC gabbert AOC
AOC is now talking about Palestine and
has come out about Palestine Julian
Assange has been called an anti-semite
Jeremy Corbyn who kind of supported as
sons didn't want him to be extradited it
doesn't
to be extradited to the US has been
called an anti-semitic racist how do you
see a Palestine playing in on these
issues we could have a long conversation
about how smearing me in Corbin and the
sergeant anybody else who criticizes the
Israeli government as anti-semites is
absurd clearly and is such a blatant and
cheap tactic and we know why they do it
we know why the Ministry of strategic
affairs in Tel Aviv
does it they do it because they have no
answer to the accusations of human
rights violations and war crimes and so
on and so forth so it's just a
smokescreen to divert attention from the
fact that our criticisms those of us who
criticize the Israeli government's
policies in the occupied territories and
in Israel itself and support BDS maybe
it's a smokescreen to divert attention
from the fact that we're right and
they're wrong I was sickened by the way
that was happening in the UK at the
Labor Party conference and the attempted
smearing of Jeremy Corbyn Corbin is a
man of great principle he also has
humanity he cares about people he
empathizes with others
Corbin has said that and I inhabit the
shadow home secretary said as science
must not be extradited I just quickly
actually I better ask you about how
Julian Assange illuminated issues like
Palestine and Yemen Britain now sending
record levels of weapons to Israel
somebody like Julian Assange willy-nilly
will be a progressive thinker that's why
he chose to do the job that he chose to
do that's why he is an activist that's
why we mentioned him in the same breath
as John Pilger because he cares about
other people he has some of the same
qualities that Jeremy Corbyn has I've
got to ask you what you would say to the
British Prime Minister and what do you
think about what will happen to Julian
Assange here in London and whether
indeed as some people say he might be
killed what I would say to British Prime
Minister I suspect that I mean I could
say anything first I'd say resign but
after that or before that I said before
you resign think carefully about handing
Julian Assange over to the Americans
except I think that would be a waste of
my breath I think I need to speak
directly to the British people I cannot
use to raise a May as a conduit to them
correcta resume is beyond redemption and
beyond help of any kind certainly from
me in my view just Tory
she's a dyed-in-the-wool post Thatcher
Tory you know I haven't no respect for
her at all she's also provided I
presided over the greatest disaster
probably in the history of those sceptre
dials and I'm talking about brexit
obviously would you say that such of the
stakes here with a search that he might
be killed or would you say that what we
should learn from this whole episode is
the importance of information and facts
they are killing us son did you see him
when he came out of the embassy he's
been living he hasn't seen hardly seen
daylight for six years having committed
no crime just because Donald Trump the
commander in chief wants him dead he may
very well end up dead that is why the
British people he called them he as he
was taken by those Special Branch
officers into that van and driven away
he called upon the people of Great
Britain to resist I heard him I watched
it on the TV resist them and they should
there should be a
general strike in England to prevent him
being extradited there should be
millions in the street like there were
before the invasion of Iraq though the
powers that be probably wouldn't take
any notice they didn't have that so
Assange we must all do everything that
we can to protect him